معنى من عمان اللواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لتحليل هذا المشهد
ونبدا بالتوزع الجغرافي لهذه الضربات
التركيه اذا من حيث المدى والحجم كيف
تقراه
يعني
كهجمات جويه لانه هناك في شمال سوريا ثلاث
عمليات رئيسيه الدرع الفرات
غسل الزيتون نبع السلام وسيطرت على مساحات
من الجغرافيا السوريه كذلك في العراق هذه
تعتبر ان حملات الجويه الرئيسيه فيما
سبقها عمليات دخلت القوات البريه في عمق
منطقه كردستان العراق اذا هي عباره عن
ضربه جويه واسعه النطاق شملت اهداف تواجد
همم حزب العمال الكردستاني البيكا كيف
شمال العراق ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكردي
المنضوي تحت ما يسمى قوات اسد في شمال
سوريا
كما ذكرت هل نفهم منه ان الجانب التركي
يتعامل مع هذه الاهداف كهدف واحد
لا هو الان حزب العمال الكردستاني هذا
معروف تاريخيا
والصراع منذ عقود ولكن وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه التي تنضوي تحت ما يسمى قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه قوات قسد يعتبر الذراع
السوري للبيكيه
الكردي وبالتالي تعتبر كان كلاهما
متحالفين من اجل تنفيذ هذا الامور
وبالتالي هي وجهت الاتهام من حيث
الهجوم الارهاب الذي حصل في منطقه تقسيم
بان الاوامر سددت من حزب العمال
الكردستاني وان الاعداد تنفيذيه هي وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكردي فاعتبرت همم اكل
الجانبين متورط سواء في عمليه التوجيه
واصدار العوامر او عمليه التنفيذ وتجنيد
همم التي
عليها الفتاه السوريه وانها دخلت قبل
اسبوع من العمليه الى غير ذلك اذا تركيه
اعتبرت كلا التنظيمين منغمسين في همم هذه
في تلك العمليه
الجانب العراقي لم يعلق ولكن لنضع في عين
الاعتبار ايضا ان ايران همم قامت ايضا
بتوجيه ضربات في شمال العراق
ويبدو ان هناك ما يشبه قلق او هاجس اقليمي
تحديدا في هذه المناطق سواء بالنسبه
لتركيا وايران هل هو بهذا الشكل
يعني
حزب العمال الكردستاني مصنف على انه تنظيم
ارهابي
وهذا مصنف على نطاق عالمي وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكردي غير مصنفه بهذا المستوى
لماذا لانها تحت المظله الامريكيه قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من يملها من يدفع
موازنتها من يقدم لها السلاح امريكا
وبالتالي حزب العمال الكردستاني متهم
باصدار العوامر وبالتالي هو على اعداء
تاريخي مع مع تركيا وهو متهم ايضا بانه هو
بمساعده الموساد من يحرك المظاهرات في
المنطقه الكرديه في ايران وانه هو المسؤول
عن عمليات القتل التي
ضباط اثنين من الحرس الثوري
الان كيف وجدت همم رد حزب العمال
الكردستاني مثلا طبعا بعدادات حمايه الشعب
او همم
جناحي ايضا في سوريا
يعني العمليه الرد هذا الرد الاني هم
متوعد وبرد قوي عندما تسمح الظروف هذا
الرد رد رد تقريبا تم اطلاق صاروخ ادى الى
اصابات الى غير ذلك هذا رد اني لكن اذا
اخذنا
بالتهديد الذي صدر على محمل الجد فبالتالي
على على تركيا ان تتوقع تنفيذ عمليات
مماثله لما حصل في منطقه تقسيم وبالتالي
سيكون هناك رد كعمليات انتحاريه او عمليات
تفجيريه الى غير ذلك في بعض المدن همم
تركيا
الخبير العسكري